um okay everyone uh we will start the
seminar but um before um introduce
today's speaker let's go over some rules
and Logistics uh first of all please
mute yourself during the talk unless you
have questions so that our speaker can
talk without unnecessary
interruptions if you have questions you
are welcome to un unmute yourself and
ask questions or use chat room post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q&A session at the end second no
classified discussion is allowed here so
watch out and finally The Talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel all right uh that's
about it now let me introduce our
speaker it is an honor to host today's
speaker Professor n Theory he's an
associate professor at the Technical
University of Munich um he is actually
an alumni of Lawrence liore which I just
found out uh in Fall of 2003 he did an
intern uh with Dr
Dan um I'm I'm not sure he's with us
right now in the seminar or not but I I
hope he he does but back then he he did
the optimization um he he optimiz he
tries to optimize the C+ C++
course now he focuses on deep learning
methods for physical systems with an
emphasis on fluid flow problems Beyond
latent space simulation algorithms and
generative models he's currently and
especially interested in learning
algorithm
powered by differentiable solvers if you
get a chance please visit his web page
you will find a list of fascinated video
clips with his beautiful folage
simulation today he will present
differentiable physics simulations for
deep learning which is aligned with our
core interest here so we expect a great
talk today now with our without further
Ado let me pass the B on to Professor
Jerry okay here you go it's all your all
right thank you thank you very much for
the
introduction exactly it's great to be
back at least virtually after doing the
internship a long time ago and today I
want to focus on the topic that that
keeps my group and and myself busy these
days and which I find very interesting
this combination of phic simulations and
deep
learning I hope I can at least show you
some first steps in in that
direction let me motivate the goal here
very broadly
so I'll be focusing on on physical
phenomena like the air around us in the
room you're sitting in so I have a
anation
here strange but hopefully you see now
the the smoke Rising
here this is a very typical phenomenon
or classical example is the flow around
an air foil one of the classical fluid
mechanics problems or
also the glass of water we drink
typically is modeled as a fluid similar
phenomena actually come up in in a large
variety of settings so one that I also
find very interesting is robotic control
so here is an example of a accurated
fish fish- like shape that that is
supposed to swim forward in the water so
this is also closely related um to these
form topics
and I don't want to cover all the
possible applications here but it goes
from thermodynamics or plasma physics
medical simulations to blood flow in our
body so there's a large variety I would
argue basically it's something that is
worth looking at it comes up a lot and I
have to show the ne St equations at
least once so this will be the basis for
many of the of the following examples
I don't want to go into detail but these
kinds of physical models is what what I
be targeting with the simulations in the
following and we actually have very
powerful method for
simulating effects like these now the
question is basically how do we combine
that with deep learning and I want to
take a very uh in a way very pragmatic
approach so the physical models are
definitely great so that that's
something to build on I think we also
have very powerful numerical methods and
developed over over a long time SP so
also these I think it's worth keeping as
much as possible and that basically
leans leaves cleaning up the the
remaining mess for the machine learning
methods and by mess I mean for example
numerical errors or um errors in
observation uncertainties
so this is how I think ideally these
different parts should play together now
one of the one of the very interesting
research questions is how to best make
these these three components work
together in the
end within this intersection of of these
different
sphar um before going into the details I
think it's also worth thinking about the
different ways this could be done on a
high level and um that's what I want to
describe here so we have a physical
system the kind of classical simulation
just goes forward we basically start
with some initial and boundary
conditions and then simul forward in
time to to find out what happens in uh
practice many applications actually also
pose inverse problems where we have
these simulations we have some
constraints or requirements and then we
have some kind of a optimization Loop to
find a solution that satisfies these
constraints in the end typically it's
still built around a simulation it
shares a lot of similarities but is is
much more complicated and in a way very
good Target for for these uh deep
learning combinations as I'll show later
on but right these two ways forward or
backward in a way are types of
simulations I'll be considering and then
the question is how to combine it with
these deep learning methods and
one straightforward way is what what I
call supervis in the following basically
treating these simulators as um
providers of data so we can col large
amounts of data and train classical
machine learning or deep learning
approaches and but as indicated by this
bar here the the connection is not very
tight what is a bit more tightly
integrated is if we use the models we
have for the simulations in in the loss
terms as soft constraints essentially
for the learning process that allows us
to incorporate more of the physics but
what I want to argue in the following is
that ideally we really very tightly
interlead these tool so ideally there
shouldn't be much of a boundary between
learning and and
simulation it's also worth mentioning
that by now this is a field that is
receiving a lot of interest and here
just a selection of some of the bomal
classical Works in this area I want to
focus on two on of my group here at the
top um these two works by by Philip and
kiwan um the primary uh pH and posts
working on this and also some additional
collaborators shown here um so these two
I think will be good examples to
illustrate this this topic and to give
an overview directly what's the goal
here talking about these differentiable
physics
simulations we typically have some pde
called p in the following
that that captures the physical model
we're interested in um with some State s
for example over time on which this PD
works and now the key quantity that is
is really useful to have here a bit
similar to classical joint optimization
is that we have a gradient of this
simulation with this Vector State s so
we'd like to know for some change of a
state how do we need to change the input
to get that desired
change and it's not something that all
simul L is necessarily provide but if we
have such a gradient that show later
this actually lets us combine simulation
very very neatly with the Deep learning
process right so basis is that we we
might have to upgrade our simulator I
should provide this quantity um but I I
hope I can show a bit that it's that's
worth doing that or considering it and
if you have such a formulation you could
have imagine actually putting a residual
or so of of the physical model into the
loss of the training
but this is actually not what what I
want to what to aim for in the
following yeah this way we can actually
achieve a very tight integration of the
two the first example that I want to
give here is is this solver in the loop
project as as we've called it and the
idea here is essentially to learn to
reduce numerical errors so working under
the assumption that these errors have
some some structure there's some pattern
to learn some repeating signal um in
these errors and we want to basically
use the network to learn how these
errors behave
and this is purely done synthetically so
could be potentially done for real data
but we're working here on on simulated
data so we assume we have some reference
here shown in blue these are essentially
reference States here of some facebase
trajectory shown in blue
coming from some higher order solver
that that we have with our
disposal and then in addition we have
some more approximate version of it we
have what what I call in the following
Source version of this this indicated by
this blue I do have a point here by this
orange blob here this I hope you can see
a bit from these these rough rectangles
this is supposed to be for example cor
calization could also be a lower order
method um hopefully it's faster than
this reference but due to the cor
approximation also introduces some
errors and what's important to note here
is that the trajectory of this orange
curve now of this orange facebase
trajectory now differs from something
that you would directly project from
this reference um solution manifold
essentially into the into the source
version and because these numerical
errors it's a typically an iterative
process they accumulate and then over
these iterated computations give us
something that's potentially quite
different from the original trajectory
and the goal is to now reach something
that is closer to the blue one so in
this case um shown as this green curve
so here we still use this approximate
solver this orange Source
simulator but we want to prove it such
that it give a result that is closer to
this reference we're interested in
and right this modification now will be
done by by a neural network to close the
gap towards these reference Solutions
and what's worth pointing out here right
away having this picture on is that this
is actually a tough task because from a
machine learning standpoint we actually
have shifting distributions of input
features so if you think of these
simulations as inputs to machine
learning model in your network then
these Source simulations typically look
different from these
reference um these reference Solutions
so typically the high dimensional very
difficult to analyze and and visualize
but if we imagine this is very simple 1D
space for example the low resolution
version might have some higher low
frequency content is the reference more
high frequency content so there's
definitely some difference in terms of
what these solvers do and we now want or
model to work with
some corrected some modified
distribution because it should start
with a source but get away from it
towards the reference but this version
here this interaction of the model and
our simulator this actually does not
exist beforehand because these versions
in the middle this this green
distribution comes from using the train
neur Network in conjunction with the
Sol and if we would do this naively
especially with pre-computation then our
model would Bally learn to rely on on
these sources and later on when we try
to apply it worst case um blow ups and
things are fine maybe give us something
that's not too different from this
Source
version um but again this is actually a
case where this using these
differentiable solvers is a very useful
tool to avoid these
problems yeah
so to formalize that a bit we have our
PD and our Solutions manifolds for the
reference in blue and this orange
manifold in Orange on the right hand
side and we assume that we have some
operator that maps from the reference to
the source space called ke in the
following the sequence of steps is then
basically obtained by repeatedly
applying our our discrete uh version of
the PD called PS here for the source um
over and time steps to obtain a solution
after an update step for example
starting from projected reference State
here and in
addition and we also have a learned
function called C here in the following
to not the correction function this is
conditioned on some set of parameters
seta this is are the parameters of the
neur network and we get some some State
some face base Point offers simulation
as
input and now the
main objective in one way to write it
down is to basically um aim for
minimizing the L2 distance between the
simulated trajectories and the projected
um reference States including the
correction in between so
um any a
way on on purpose we have a very simple
combination here so we just take these
states and add an output of the network
on top potentially you could have some
more complicated operations here
but the network in itself is already
nonlinear and we assume that we have
some additive correction in the
F yeah so the goal is to minim minimize
the difference between these two overall
States um over
time yeah so to come back to this very
simple supervisor example it's also good
to put that in context here and in this
case we have our reference solver we
compute a large amount of data we use a
source solver to compute the
same uh to set up the same um initial
conditions and obtain a cause
approximation of these Solutions and
then we can train a network just based
on these differences so the network in
this orange arrow here the C function
now basically just sees the difference
between these reference States and the
output and as shown before and then in
any deep learning framework we have
gradients for all the operations of the
neural network so this is just back
propagated um towards the weights met to
obtain an update and basically train the
network to to minimize the difference of
these two as you can see the solvers are
all in the data generation Step at the
top they're not playing any role in the
in the training
process which I think is is a Pity in
away um and like this is something to
move away from then we can iterate this
process so with these residual
formulations we can do a bit better so
here we can again look at the network
and now have some residual formulation
of our pde in the
loss again minimizing the difference
towards the reference this is unmodified
but now we basically back propagate
through both this residual in the loss
and then propagate the gradient that we
obtained at the output of the network
basically further into the network to
update the weights so to
before and now we basically have our
physical model in the residual or parts
of it um and one of the one of the nice
side effects here is that um in many
cases we can directly use derivatives of
this neur network to formulate the
residual
but also as visible in the the color
scheme here again this the whole solver
actually comes not into play here so
especially if you think about time
iteration Evolution over time we don't
actually use the solver or information
from it in this training process we have
some version of the of the physical
model of the PD but not the actual
solver and this is what I want to um
now um make use of here so having a
solare that gives us this gradient
um is actually I would also argue a a
good thing because we can choose the
good distalization having knowledge
about the physical model about numerical
methods that we want to use we can set
up our solver and then also the
calculation of the gradient to
use the numerical methods the accuracies
and the orders that we would like to get
for our approximation
um side point here is that we typically
need to take care not to make this too
fine grain we don't want every addition
multiplication to be taken into account
but something on the order of of time
steps or larger and larger updates
within our Sol typically Mak
sense and a good example is a classical
P solve here so if we have a line system
with a laass matrix and we're interested
in inverting that so if we as a solution
actually want to compute a inverse times
some right hand side B if we now
interested in this gradient so the
derivative with respect to B that
actually just leaves the exact same
inversion of of the Matrix a and if we
have
some um some efficient iterative solver
to compute this invers Matrix Al method
or or a CG solver then we can actually
use the same efficient solver both for
the forward and the backward pass in the
setup and right having basically well
chosen method here typically also then
makes the learning process later on much
faster yeah and once we have done this
for some pieces in our simulation then
typically it's actually quite easy to um
to put together these different steps
with um with automatic differentiation
of some of the deep learning
packages oh I just saw that there's a
um there's a question about richardon
extrapolation um I would argue that it's
a very different process and with with
Rich Richardson extrapolation it's also
aiming for reducing the errors um but
here we have a whole neural network that
is added to a solution and that is in a
way very problem dependent and train to
minimize the errors just for that set of
CAS cases that it's seen at a training
time in the end it's also basically
added on top um with a similar goal but
a very different representation of of
reducing the
error so potentially less generic but I
would hope that actually by training
this correctly you could could do better
than the orist extrapolation I haven't
we haven't compared this in particular
for these
examples that would be interesting to
try
yeah so in this context here we still
looking at the time Evolution so we have
some roll out of our simulator and now
the main difference is that we not only
have a PVE but also this function C that
depends on on the states we're producing
so this is one of the key changes
here the solver basically determines the
face based trors we get and now having a
PD solver and some potentially
non-trivial uh nonlinear function in in
our neural network will most likely give
us very different evolutions of our
system and this is basically also what
we need to to work with as a basis for
Corrections in order to stick to the
reference so these states here are now
denoted with this tier to distinguish
them from the kind of plain um sour
simulation
State and now right the collection
function actually
works with these modified States as
tiller as inputs and needs to learn to
adjust to to their
content in a way the the minimization
itself looks very similar to
before with an important difference now
being that we use these modified States
as inputs to our system which actually
depend on what the correction function
has has produced
beforehand and I think visually this is
in a way much easier to to see so now
the main idea as often mentioned as a
goal before is we really directly use
the solver in this training grouop and
now for for one single update of the
Network rates we can start with some
um projected uh reference configuration
evaluate a network and then passes
through the solver and we really do this
up to up to the end times we're
interested in as much as as our
computational uh resources
allow then we can go in and now check
what Solutions we obtained and how the
loss what the loss looks like over the
course of this Evolution and for each of
these we can now with the right solver
actually back propagate through the
simulation so we have the adjoint of the
of the whole um solver in the training
process we get a gradient this is back
propagated into the network to update
the wav and the loss is actually also
computed and here we can now use this
this suitable hopefully well chosen disc
calization of our solver both for the
forward step and for the adjoint method
um for the adjoint of the
solver and we do actually in this case
have a loss for every step in between
having reference
States um from our from some reference
solver and
and all of these updates of the of the
seta weights are toally accumulated so
all these together give us one single
update of of the network
weights and um what what really is the
key difference here to to the previous
two methods is that in this case in a
way the correction function sees its
effect over time this is really in a way
Computing a full simulation with nend
steps at a training time and H you can
imagine that if this deviates we'll
actually see it in the loss and the
correction function basically get the
signal to respect um these changes that
occur over over the time Evolution and
all of this is done for one single
update step so at the end we have one
gradient for Network R thata and then we
can keep on iterating
here to overtime train our Network to
but hopefully bring down the whole error
across these across these different
States yeah
um
right for for chotic systems I think
this is an interesting question maybe I
show some more examples this I think
this is a good good point for for an
Outlook let me show some some simple
examples first um not too too chaotic
for now so um a nice example is a a
simple w flow so we have a rectangular
domain we have an inflow with a with a
round obstacle in the the lower half we
have a certain range of Ros numbers as
training data and some new Ros numbers
um as test
data and here on the right you can now
see the the reference versions at the
bottom and these corser approximations
of the forest space at the
top and this is already a good point to
look a bit at the differences so here we
can just compute the mean absolute error
um between these
two
so this is these this number of of
0.14 between the two states here and
this now basically quantifies a bit how
how different the solutions are visually
it's they obvious and but in terms of um
of direct error so this is some
normalized um
these are some normalized quantities
here and now if we bring in the solver
so the solver in the loop model so this
train Network for this case we can
actually get solutions that are very
close to the reference and in this case
we get significantly lower Arrow of
0.013 and Visually I think it's hard to
distinguish and these numbers now are
also useful to um to illustrate these
shft
distributions So This blured Out Source
version
and from this from this um solution
manifold that I showed initially this is
now basically this
0.14 uh away from the reference at least
in terms of its
mean and this learned corrected version
is now much closer so it we we really
can measure the distance at least in
terms of the mean here and by training
with the solver in the process here that
basically makes it possible to
um to learn from that shifted
distribution so if we set it up
correctly and this learning process
actually converges then in the end the
network will actually have learned to
work with these changing states and to
to use those States as input to produce
a a good reference distribution
um there's
also I can show this in motion here this
is the force
version um sorry this is a lower number
case for The Source on the left the
reference on the right and in the middle
there's this hybrid that uses Source
solver so it's actually based on the
same version as the right one but with
that edit correction from the neuron
Network and this is the higher R number
case
and Visually I think
um it's good to see that these are very
close and that's the the numbers um you
can find more additional details in the
paper if you're interested there and
it's also worth mentioning that this uh
joint training with the solver
actually um improves the
generalization which I think is a very
important aspect of it so it slightly
different setup here we have a basically
some some passively attractive quantity
that we assume it's hot some simple buyy
model with withes
approximation and in this case
um you could test out a bit how FX how
well this model works with different
boundary conditions and um I think this
this did work quite well um one of the
reasons being that having the solware in
the training basically allows the
network also to see or generate from
changing states different configurations
of the simulator and training time and
that typically helps robustness and
avoids overfitting to the specific
inputs um in in some input
data yeah I briefly want to come back to
these different approaches here um to to
make the difference a bit clearer so
with the supervisor basically right we
cannot use any numerical methods easily
it's just based on the data and right
there's there's no model behind it um
with the oh sorry with the
um the physics and formed approaches
with some additional loss terms we can
use make use of the model in the
training but again because um this is
typically used using neur networks to
formulate our
PVE this basically prevents us from
using a large portion of numerical
methods um that typically don't work
with new networks and in a way with this
with this differential physics approach
we we relying on a full kind of regular
solver um both for for predictions and
for getting information about the
training so here we can actually use the
existing numerical tools that we have
and so also shows a bit on the on the
representation for each so the super
supervis approach actually what um is in
a way the most flexible we could do this
for for for anything for any kind of
mesh I'll actually only show Regular
cartisian meeses in the following
potentially also this could be a more
unstructured mesh in a way that would
transfer quite nicely
these uh these series form constraints
typically work with fully connected
neural network it's quite a different
representation and um I it's
interleaving also typically uses a
regular mesh where we can then use some
to do discreation on on that mesh
directly yeah
um this I just briefly mentioned so far
that there is this look ahead in the in
the time
Evolution so in every step of the
training we basically unroll the the
physical prediction to let the network
get a signal how the system evolves and
this is compared here on this slide so
the supervised training here that is the
the version that basically just uses
pre-computed data in this case it's
actually showing the
Improvement between the source and the
reference States so starting from the
source just to have it in in a direct in
a direct comparison so is now relative
improvement over the over the source
inputs and it doesn't do badly it gives
us a like roughly 30% Improvement but
that's not too close to the
references and if we include the solver
with four steps we at 41% and in this
case it actually paid off to train with
steps um of the solver um in every
single update of the
network in this case we actually get
more than than twice the Improvement of
the of the supervised version so in this
case a beauty paid off to have very long
predictions also makes it considerably
more expensive to train the network but
the hope is that if we train this for
for an interesting space one that is
General enough to be interesting for for
a variety of of new inputs then
hopefully we can use this train model
many times in the future so that this
this onetime cost is
offset and the 3D case is also
interesting because there we
see more clear problems of the of the
supervis approach in in 2D actually
worked relatively well with this 30%
Improvement if we Tred to do the same
for a 3D flow so again this wake flow
with a cylinder in this case and as you
can see here on the left the network
really leads to not a complete blow up
but but to very strong
artifacts and this most likely actually
caused by these shifting uh shifting
distributions in the inputs
and
um especially in the direct comparison
the hybrid version with the solver in
the loop model um behaves much closer to
the to the reference solution here again
shown on the right hand
side um it does not show up that much in
the the terms of the mean absolute error
but this would be interesting to analyze
with respect to other um other metrics
as
well um
yeah oh and uh also one fun fact was
mentioning here in the paper which shows
it's with a white background and that
actually nicely shows that it's more
about fish smoking cigars but yeah side
note what is worth uh another comment is
the performance because in the end
also all this training here actually
uses the these reference States as as a
training goal so we assume that we
actually have some synchronized
simulation where we have Bally guiding
signal towards reference for the
different Source States and having this
in a way it's a question of of
computational resources so it's more
expensive but we wanted to pay off in
terms of the resources that we need to
produce either each of these um
different solutions and for the 3D flow
actually the numbers are still fairly
clear so here we had a CPU based solver
that took around 900
seconds and only the source
server with with the neural network um
take around 13 14 seconds so this is a
nice speed up and of course this is
comparing a CPU version to one that
partially uses the the GPU so this is
not fully Fair uh to be
fa both are also not super optimized I
think there's plenty of room on on both
of these sides um to further speed
things up and also this reference solver
is still a relatively simple one I could
imagine that for more complicated ones
actually the time would go up a lot also
for um for larger gaps in terms of
resolution with the super linear scating
I think these um reference dates stes
could become very expensive and we could
see larger speedups and one other thing
that I think is worth mentioning here is
also that for these neur networks at the
moment at least I think it's very
promising to or not a bad idea to rely
on future Hardware um I think these the
the recent mechs that came out are a
nice indicator um they actually had a
nice number of of dedicated units for
evaluating neur networks so if we have a
trained model here I think at least for
the next couple of years we'll see
massive improved massively improved
support in hardware for evaluating these
models so I would expect that this model
even without any changes will run
potentially much faster on on future
architectures yeah
um
so this was in a way a relatively
controlled setup learning to reduce
these numerical errors I want to mention
a um second
approach that is quite in line but
targets a slightly different goal for
for control from the following paper
here and here the goal is a
bit The Learning goal is a bit less
direct so here I imagine that that the
setup is we have some kind of um r with
with an air flow and Imagine The Fire
breaks out and now we have some L well
that we can control so indicated by the
green errors here so we cannot directly
modify the air or the smoke here but we
want to now control these valves such
that the smoke is for example blown out
of out of the closest
window and so this is now Less Direct
before with this with the numerical
errors we could basically just add
things anywhere in our solution and here
now we need to control these in and
Outlets such that the smoke is for
example blowing in a certain
direction this turned out to be a um
substantially more difficult problem so
here we cannot rely on a single Network
anymore but the time also makes this
quite challenging we still kept it
relatively simple setting a fixed um a
fixed time interval and and reaching the
target after a fixed number of of time
steps and of a fixed hor horon but
within that time Horizon of again end
steps the the evolution is actually not
constrained at all in a way we don't
care how the system evolves over time as
long as the goal in the end is reached
and that complexity actually required a
second Network that in a way you can see
it as a plan it basically predicts what
state we'd like to reach at one of the
one of the intervals in time and then we
have a second Network which now is bit
more similar to the previous one that
actually acts that for example changes
these these
exhausts and right from that we get a
new state and then the first Network can
again predict what we'd like to get out
for the for the remaining time and then
the second Network can correct so it's a
predictor corrector scheme
essentially despite this it actually
chained in a very similar way so now we
have right this Action Network called CF
here again taking the current state as
input and having a certain number of
Weights this case it also needs to know
about the Target Target and the time
it's a slightly different input but
relatively similar one of the key
differences in learning now is that we
really only have a loss for the final
States so before we had this this
aligned um data set and here now we just
have some final goals St that we'd like
to reach
um so the loss is really in this case or
needs to back propagate from the final
State all the way through this uned
sequence um to update the weights in the
network these are then um we variated
still for every every one of the time
steps such that the N can act on the on
the difference in between as
well that's right visually I think this
shows that the whole unrolling process
with this differentiable so solver is is
quite similar to
before yeah so this is now our our fire
setup um looking a bit simpler here so
this is a 2d n sto simulation 128 squar
um over 16 time steps and was also was
mentioning in a way right this being a
control problem for deep learning you
might intuitively think of of
reinforcement learning as a tool here
but um we have actually some we have
tried to compare a
bit um but this is extremely difficult
for reinforcement learning despite this
relatively simple setup we have more
than 5,000 continuous control parameters
here so this is a very large action
space as it's call it in RL and um hence
it's actually very unstable with these
methods and here but you can basically
rely on the solver and on on directional
information from the solver so this
we able to train quite nicely with the
with this differential physics approach
and here are different samples from our
test set of different initial con
configurations and basically different
Windows selected at the top of the
domain and as I hope you can see here
bit the network basically adds these
forces on the outer blue Sid to push
around the fluid in the middle and to
move it towards um one of the one of the
outlets at the top
yeah um this is this is basically what I
want to mention for this control project
there are add
additional examples potentially again in
the in the supplemental material of the
paper also for some other um systems
like like bers
equation um
but showing these two examples I think
it's a good point to to give an Outlook
so what we also quite interested in as
as next steps is to look at real data as
mentioned before both of these examples
I've shown you with synthetic data so
simulated inputs but it would be really
interesting to use real world data some
some measured um flows and we actually
have a small capture set up for this um
with the the fork machine so some some
visual floats you can see it here in
this Orange
Outlet now it's playing so and producing
some some hot um hot air plumes
basically these we can reconstruct with
some traditional convex optimization
schemes and we
have nice collection of these U captured
re World
flows this will be a very interesting
direction to use
similar learning with model equations to
reconstruct or learn from these real
world
flows there are also some interesting
synergies between visional Graphics
applications so looking at time
Evolutions we also had one one step at
at super resolution techniques for for
videos video be time signals and here a
version that actually also again takes
the time Evolution into account is shown
at the top right here this Tech
approach um while the input in this case
is the lower left so it's very pixelated
as you can see and the ground tool is
shown at the bottom right some previous
work at the at the top left um I think
that this is
also a nice nice base for for Combined
works
and in the long run I think what
will be a very interesting challenge of
course the goal is to scale this up to
really large simulations I've shown
relatively small ones here and this is
an example from one of our earlier Works
where we also had a super resolution
Network for these um smoke flows for
Scala transport and in this case it's a
3D CNN that is just used in different
places of the simulation here we had
around thousand cells across one axis so
over time this really produces billions
of of
cells and scaling these methodes up to
these and much larger systems I think
will be an interesting uh challenge
because typically because of all the non
larities um it can be difficult and
things
don't often don't always work out as
expected but of course I think this
really an interesting and a very
important goal for practical
applications yeah so with that I also
want to come to to a conclusion so I
hope I was able to demonstrate a bit
that having these differential solvers
is a good tool to Bridge simulations and
learning and you have the Deep learning
components in one side and the numerical
methods and physical models on the other
side um I showed this eror correction
and control
task um one Outlook that I also want to
mention here is numerical weather
prediction in a way also very complex
fluid
systems where we have some data actually
not that much if you think about in
terms of learning but I think this will
be a very interesting and important
Challenge and to to use similar ideas
for predicting weather and
climate
and one one of the key messages to to
phrase it very bluntly in a way as to
write te tear down borders between these
different parts that we have here so I
think there's no no good reason to see
these as separated systems but ideally
we we have a free flow of information so
the actual signal or actual Solutions
but also any higher order derivatives
that we might
need ideally passed without any problems
between learning and and simulator
component and there's a nice citation
here from a Norwegian explorer that he
actually meant for for borders in the
real world which arguably even more
important but I think it's a nice
mindset also for
simulations um to ideally not have any
artificial borders between at a deep
learning and and a
simulator and in the long run um
bringing these two together should also
hopefully also improves our
understanding of these
processes um this I think is
potentially very exciting and important
goal in the long run um and I haven't I
haven't even touched here properly the
the problems that arise but um I think
that there is a decent hope
that we as humans can actually also
learn from these train models it's not
just a blackbox we can analyze it it is
some representation in a computer and
hopefully these will actually at some
point also give us better understanding
and and potentially better models or
insights about what happens in in nature
around us so as as a very long-term goal
and with that yeah I want to thank you
for your attention the examples I've
shown here we're actually done with our
um differential solver called f flow
which you can find under the link here
if you're interested this is an open
source project and uh feel free to try
it out and let us know how it works and
at this point i' also like to to thank
my collaborators again and the funding
by the USC and
Intel thanks for listening I'd be happy
to answer some
questions thank you so much uh it was
really interesting talk and definitely I
totally agree with you um we need more
research on this directions okay we have
a um many questions on the chat room uh
so let's start uh with Jeremy's
question okay um is the reducing
numerical eror solver in the loop
procedure analogous to resar and
extrapolation is the cost comparable I
think you comment on that people right
this I briefly commented on I think it
is quite different so I don't have the
exact cost for for Richardson ex
relation in mind but instead of relying
on a on a direct extrapolation of the
solver here we basically need to only
evaluate this network um it's worth
keeping in mind that for this one and
for other works at the moment they're
actually not that tiny they typically
have a fair number of degrees of freedom
and so it's also definitely not for
free but keeping Hardware in mind I I do
have a hope that in the end they will be
very efficient to evaluate the in a way
it's a very structured process of
elating
these regular fully connected networks
or convolutional ones
um but I think overall it's it's quite
different okay uh the next question from
box young uh do the high resolution
simulation and the low resolution
simulation need to be synchronized in
their state space in order to prepare
the training data that's also a good
question so um what we need is
distalization of the same PD so we do
need basically different solvers for the
same problem formulation
um I haven't mentioned in the talk but
the the reference spacee that is
actually relatively could be considered
as a black box so in way this could be
pre-computed we need some reference data
it could also maybe come come from from
some experiment from measurements but
then we need a process that tries to
recreate these reference dates and makes
errors and then we'd like to close the
gap between the two so as such we do
need some
synchronization and this approximate
version of it that we actually need in a
differentiable way in the training
process okay uh another one from boxan
uh would gradient blow or diminish in
iterative
computation yes it is it is
definitely more difficult to train
because potentially your PVE is very
nonlinear you have a nonlinear uh neural
network that interacts with it modifies
it um so this is difficult to train
however in practice um we we also
discussed it a bit in the paper what for
example Works nicely to stabilize it is
that you build up the time evolution
you could in extreme case actually
pre-compute a supervised model and then
slowly add more and more steps over time
if you directly try to work with 100
simulation steps and an untrained model
then it's bound to blow up but building
it up in this way actually works quite
stably in
practice okay um here is a question from
grg is there a limitation where there is
a potion of the initial condition space
is chaotic uh that is near neighbor
initial conditions produce Divergent
answers in the well resolved simulation
cause trouble for the
method so that's also good question so
one of the one of the key advantages of
this differential physics approach is
actually that we don't um we don't just
average over different potentially
chaotic modes of a
solution um but we get a gradient for
the current current state of our
system and if things go well actually we
can find solutions that
then recreate particular parts of of the
solution manifold whereas in normal
supervis burning you would basically
pre-compute scattered points of of these
chotic states and then average them out
to learn mean which I think in many
applications would be
worse um however I can imagine that if
if the space is very chaotic then it it
will be very difficult to learn so it's
definitely challenging if you have
chaotic systems but I think compared to
some something simpler like supervised I
think it's a good idea to have have
gradients information from a
solver okay another question from shu
um it's a similar question how did you
deal with the instability for ad joint
for chaotic
system and we
actually did
not um see specific
instabilities in the in the Ed joins
themselves in these uh
computation um in the example that I've
shown so typically the learning
process was the was the more fragile
component of the
two I could imagine that for for cases
where this is
problematic um the clasic literature on
on a joint method maybe has some
solutions there or having um basically
having this the symetry between the
forward solve and the backward solve
potentially and you can
stabilize both with method
together um right we actually haven't
accounted that in our test so
far okay um question from lit uh can you
comment on how transferable this method
is when you wish your neural network to
span a space of simulations say varying
with a Ros number in the context of cfd
can you train in parallel across
multiple simulations solving slightly
different
problems right so regarding
generalization I think it's a very
important point and in a way the the
disappointing answer that I I have to
give here is that normally these these
networks don't don't magically
transferred to to new uh to new inputs
rather what from our experience is very
important is that you set up the
training to cover typical input that you
want to work with later on
um that being said I think it is
actually having solware in the loop is
actually a very powerful tool and you
can make it very generic by a training
time providing
randomized varying initial conditions
such that the network sees typical
different
inputs and um i' I've briefly shown this
example with the hot
smoke that model actually did very
nicely work with input conditions that
were very different from the on that the
the training data set but I think it's
important to basically set up the
training process to really show these or
some similar conditions at training time
if you only train with a certain type of
inputs and then later on completely
change it and hope that the model works
on something very different that
typically does not work and a way models
are good at adapting to to the cases
they seen and they have seen and
basically focus on minimizing the errors
and they they're given all the all the
inputs
um
so I think that's important to keep in
mind when setting up the trading okay um
question from Brenda can you elaborate
on the design of your
CNN you injecting also your control
problem was that done in the context of
supervised learning or
reinforc learning
and simple fully convolutional CNN and
injecting the physics knowledge is
really done with it solver so there is
no additional magic in the CNN the CNN
is a very simple one key is really
having the for that provide a gradient
to the output of the
CNN
and it's we haven't I haven't used or
shown any any of the RL examples here we
have some internally um for for simpler
problems they typically work quite badly
um so training with here topic be paid
off quite a
bit and I think you could call it
partially un unsupervised because for
many these cases the the solutions are
computed on the
fly so it's not is you just using
pre-computed
data and right although this
unsupervised area in classic machine
learning Al it's a bit vague because I
would argue in in the end you always
need some signal to supervise the
network it's more of a question whether
it's computed on the fly
or computation is what called
supervised
yeah okay
um question from can comment on memory
scaling related to back propagating uh
through a Time integrator
and it definely requires more memory and
we haven't benchmarked it in in full
detail but you can you can basically
estimate that you need on the order of
the time steps within between for your
for your network and for your
solver um and then like potentially a
bit more over had for um for things like
um for additional normalization or or
whatever momentum terms or so that your
Optimizer
includes so um these are typically
needed for the back propagation right
for for for computing the derivative to
to the the stat that you obtained in a
forward path um you could partially
recompute those but it's it's quite
memory intensive as are actually new
networks typically especially cnns can
produce lot of basically a lot of data
in terms of some abstract features in
the in the hidden layers and so that can
lead to
some sub substantial memory
overhead I mean in practice we we
haven't optimized that much I could
think it could be
reduced um but it definitely
requires on the order of this rolling of
time steps and
more okay from James what were the
challenges of
getting five flow to work with the auto
differentiation in py or tensor
flow that's a good question too I think
there were no
um there were no inherent challenges
but also for us it was a bit of a
learning
process to learn how these Frameworks
work um so actually a very
straightforward way to implement these
solvers would be to just take the basic
operations Say by tcation and so on from
from these Frameworks and um then
realizing right solver with those it
turns out that is that is a very bad
idea that is very slow we actually do
have a CG solver I think in P flow that
just uses basic tensor for
operations and to some extent it's
interesting to also backr through the
full CG solve but um in a way having
some knowledge of the solver and knowing
which states are interesting it's
typically important to um not not expose
all those intermediate states to a to
some framework like
tensorflow and if if we know that we
don't that we're not interested in any
of these intermediates then we can not
store them not um not keep um the the
the bo path Solutions in memory
so for efficiency that actually is quite
important I would say to to think a bit
about which states are important where
we need the gradi which should be kept
in
memory okay the question from Rob uh
it's clear that having a differentiable
physics solver can lead to some very
nice method as you have shown today the
challenge for complex coupled
multiphysic solvers which may be
comprised of multiple physics libraries
and sub components how do we introduce
differentiation throughout this complex
software and numerical method chain is
automatic differentiation a viable
approach for large multi physics codes
in your
opinion I have to bit I don't think I
can reliably answer that on the spot I
think this the sounds very challenging
and I think it also depends on what your
multif physics system consists of
I think it is worth investigating and I
think this is also a very interesting
question for for future research how to
best compute certain quantities that
that guide learning across very complex
and nonlinear ass
simulators but definitely in such a case
I think you would need to be very
careful with with that sizes with
Vanishing or exploding
gradients um so it sounds
difficult but right I I think it's very
also very problem dependent
unfortunately so great topic for
research but out of the box I don't know
yeah okay all right well Martin asked
the question but um he think you have
already answered so with that I I don't
have any more questions unless someone
add you directly to your private set
would you quickly check whether
anyone I don't
think have additional questions no I
don't think there any
addition okay well with that I I think
well let's thank our today's speaker
Neil uh it was wonderful talk and we
really appreciate it um yeah close thank
you thank you thanks for the invitation
yeah thank you for listening
and hopefully in the future the pandemic
uh situation gets better and we can
actually host you in person hopefully
that that's it's going to happen in the
future well I'm looking forward all
right okay thank you so
much bye everyone and thank you everyone
uh to joining our seminar today
okay bye
goodbye oh hi NE uh um would you are you
still there yes I would you would you
send the slid
today because I have to go through some
review and approval process in order to
upload it into the YouTube so okay yes I
think I can I still have a PDF okay
think I can send it to you right yeah
yeah okay sounds good thank you again
Neil yeah thanks bye bye